el sonido de las bombas se ha vuelto
habitual en los últimos días la lucha
continúa en nagorno karabaj y tanto las
fuerzas de azerbaiyán y armenia buscan
mostrar cómo se golpean entre sí con
ataques aéreos
una guerra de propaganda con víctimas
reales que se acumulan en ambos lados
en la capital de azerbaiyán los hombres
hacen fila para enlistarse y unirse a la
primera línea de batalla
aunque nuestro ejército es fuerte viene
aquí a mostrar a nuestro gobierno que
estoy listo estamos listos para proteger
nuestra tierra en cualquier momento en
las calles de yereván los armenios
muestran sensaciones encontradas
no queremos guerra pero si no las
imponen vamos a pelear
quiero que todas las partes vuelvan a la
mesa de negociaciones lo único que deseo
es paz golpes el último estallido en un
conflicto de larga data inició el
domingo en nagorno karabaj región
declarada parte de azerbaiyán tras la
división de la unión soviética pero que
ha permanecido largamente bajo control
de separatistas armenios respaldados por
el gobierno
una guerra total terminó con alto el
fuego mediado por rusia en 1994 pero
ningún acuerdo de paz formal se firmó
desde entonces mientras eeuu en rusia y
alemania han pedido el cese de los
enfrentamientos
turquía aliado de azerbaiyán dijo estar
lista para ayudar a bakú a recuperar lo
que calificó como tierras ocupadas y
sólo 16 bases la solución al problema es
simple y hay una sola armenia debe
retirarse de los territorios que ha
ocupado en azerbayán si eso no ocurre el
conflicto no podrá ser resuelto sin más
armenia acusó a turquía de derribar uno
de sus aviones de combate algo que
ankara niega de ser cierto derivaría en
una escalada significativa del conflicto